afternoon everyone my name is nora
volkov and i'm the director of the
national
institute on drug abuse at the nih and
it's a real
pleasure for me to introduce dr xiaowei
schwang who is a professor of chemistry
and chemical biology
and professor of physics at harvard
university
she dr suwang pioneered the development
of single molecule
super resolution and genomic scale
imaging methods
for the studies of biological systems
among the methods
include storm a super resolution imaging
method
and using it she discovered novel novel
cellular structures
another method is murphy a single cell
transcriptome imaging method
that allows her to elucidate gene
expression regulation in cells
and the molecular identities spatial
organization
and functions of cells in tissues a
third method
is a multiplex fish method that allows
direct visualization
of the three-dimensional organization of
chromatin in the cell nucleus
schwann did her undergraduate degree in
physics from the university of science
and technology
of china she did her phd degree in
physics
under the supervision of professor g.r
shen from the university of california
at berkeley
her postdoctoral training in biophysics
in the lab
of professor steven shu at stanford
university
she joined harvard's faculty in 2001
and became a howard huge medical
investigator in 2005.
dr swank has received numerous awards
and honors
including membership in both the united
states
and chinese academy of sciences and has
been the recipient of some of the most
prestigious
science awards for her accomplishments
in biophysics and neuroscience
her presentation title is single cell
transcriptome imaging and brain cell
atlas
and before i leave you with her i want
to remind the audience
to please type your questions in the
question
and answer box during the presentations
i enjoy enjoy the presentation
thank you for the kind introduction it's
my great pleasure to speak at the sixth
annual
brain initiative investigator meeting so
i will talk about
our uh recent work on this
single cell transcriptome imaging method
that my lab developed
and our application of this method
to generate a cell analysis of a couple
of brain regions
so first let me give you a motivation of
why we want to develop a single cell
transcriptome energy method
now we know that animals are made up of
many different types of cells
any cells have different behaviors and
functions largely because they have for
different
gene expression profiles and therefore
being able to quantify
the rna expression profile or the
transcriptome of individual cells
could greatly help our understanding of
the molecular origin of different cell
behaviors
and indeed the recent advancing singles
rna sequencing has begun to transform
many areas of biology so then why do we
want to develop a
imaging-based single-star
transcriptomics approach
now uh one of the main reasons
is because imaging-based approaches
allow us to do spatially resolved
measurement
and that is important in at least two
fronts
and now at the cellular level we know
that rnas are not uniformly distributed
inside cells
and the local rna distributions and the
actions are actually important it is an
important post-transformational
regulation form and it is important for
the
establishment and maintenance of local
cellular structures
as described in this beautiful review by
rob
singer and at a tissue level
we also know as i said there are so many
different types of cells
and these cells are also not uniformly
distributed
and the spatial organization of the
different cell types
is actually important for the tissue
function so if we could actually do in
situ single cell gene expression
profiling
then we can identify the cell types in
situ
and then with that directly map out this
functionally
important spatial organization
so how do we do this so here's our idea
we use aerobusted barcoding
combinatorial labeling and sequential
imaging
to enable simultaneous measurements of
numerous
genes or numerous rna species so what we
first do is we encode individual rna
species with unique barcodes
for example binary barcodes and then we
use combinatorial labeling
to physically imprint the barcodes onto
each rna molecule so i'll explain how to
do that
and then we sequentially image we use
sequential imaging to read out these
sparkles
bit by bit now in the first round of
labeling and imaging we image only those
rnas their first bit
reads one but not zero and then we
remove the signal
and in the second round we read out
those rnas their second bit reads one
but not zero
and so on and so forth so
at the end of imaging for each cell we
see many many dots inside the cell
and each represents an rna molecule and
then each one now has a string of binary
barcode associated with it
depending on which round of imaging that
we detected
so then how do we actually label and
image
these are nice and eating individual
rounds
and we use this powerful single molecule
fish method
that's pioneered by ralph singer and
further advanced
by rob singer arjun raj and others into
a highly accurate and quantitative
method in which individual rnas are
detected by
a complementary oligo that's
fluorescently labeled that allow us to
image locate and count those rna
molecules
so how do we achieve this very large
scale
imaging or combinatorial labeling this
is what we do
so we first add a high diversity library
of encoding probes to the sample
and then each one of these encoding
probes have a target region that allow
it to specifically recognize
a target molecule and these readout
sequences
that are determined by you know the
target molecules
uh binary barcode for example so for
example if we have
the sparkles read to 1 0 1 1 and so on
so then the encoding probe of this rna
would encode include
readout sequence one but not two
read out sequence three and four but not
five and so on and so forth
and then once it's encoding step or the
imprinting of the encode
of the codes that is finished
we then read out these sparkles bit by
bit
by using now readout probes that are
firstly labeled
and complementary to the readout
sequences to detect
you know which bit of the barcodes reads
one
so with this approach then we reached
a very large scale
imaging of numerous rna species as i'll
show you with an experimental proof
later but i also want to say that with
this two-step
re encoding and readout probe labeling
this also allows the cellular rnas to be
uh
labeled relatively fast now one
immediate advance
or advantage of this method is scaling
and you can see that after n bit imaging
or in round imaging with single color
imaging or
you know three color imaging was n
divided by three rounds of energy
so how many different rna species can we
distinguish
we can distinguish two to the ends of
rnas
now uh if say if n is only equal to
16 that would allow already allow us to
detect some 65 000 rnas
there is also a problem and that problem
is error propagation and accumulation
now even though as i mentioned single
molecule fish
is accurate and that means for each bit
the measurement
error is small but that error will add
up from multiple bits
so uh for uh for example 16 bits
then that error could be very
substantial and we solve this problem by
using codes
that allows error detection and
correction
for example in this hanging code with a
hemming distance four
that means between any pair of valid
barcodes
four bit errors has to occur now each
bit
occur with a relatively small chance
then having four errors simultaneously
occur in a message
makes that chance even smaller moreover
if a single bit error occurs
we can actually detect that and not only
detect that but
also corrected that because that would
generate a message
that is closed uniquely close to a
correct message and at least three
errors away from other messages
so with that we achieved both large
scale imaging and high accuracy
so we call this method multiplexed air
robust fluorescence in situ
hybridization or
murfish so here's an experimental proof
as you can see in this first murphish
paper
we imaged the uh in this case 140 genes
and then we can see that the measurement
results
correlate very well with bulk sequencing
and then we can also compare with a
single molecule fish
for 15 of the 140 genes and then get
basically spot on agreement which also
shows a very high detection efficiency
of this approach
and then we also detected a thousand
genes
and still get very good correlation with
spoke sequencing
so in other words even in this initial
work we demonstrated the transcriptome
scale energy
of a thousand genes now i should say
that by using a single slide showing
this i really did not do justice to the
tremendous amount of work that we
actually did
to make this possible it actually took
us multiple years of effort
between the conception of the idea and
the publication of this paper
so after conceiving the idea i actually
set our goal of the very first
publication to be
a thousand gene imaging to demonstrate
the genome scale imaging experimentally
and as i said it took us multiple years
of hard work to overcome
many challenges in labeling imaging
analysis and so on to reach this scope
and then more recently we scaled up
further to show that
we can image ten thousand genes uh more
than ten thousand genes
was basically the same approach and the
same type of pending code
but just a longer code and we maintain
the very high detection efficiency and
accuracy
so i should say that the high detection
efficiency of
murfish is another advantage of this
genome scale
measurement approach for example
compared to a single cell rna sequencing
so there are a variety of applications
so that one could use this uh
murphy for for example things these are
single cell measurements
and then in each individual cell so we
measure the expression of many genes
and then by comparing the genes their
expression level how do they vary from
cell to cell
or how do they co-vary from cell to cell
we can actually infer gene regulatory
networks as
we've already done in our first paper
and then obviously we could measure the
spatial organization
of the rnas at the transcriptome scale
inside the cell
and then we can measure the spatial
organization of cells in complex tissues
and we've also demonstrated
using this approach where we can do
image based the high throughput
screening of
port genetic libraries such as a crispr
based support library approach
but actually screen based on the
phenotypes that are only accessible
by imaging and then we can also use
multiplexes fish
to measure uh numerous uh
chromatin both sides and then use that
to trace out the 3d organization of
chromatin
inside the cells but in this work as i
mentioned in the beginning
we'll focus on our cell atlas effort
and the idea again is to use murfish to
do in-situ
gene expression profiling of individual
cells
and then to identify cell types based on
these gene expression profiles
and then directly map out the spatial
organization of these spell types
and then i'll talk about our work in two
different brain regions
and i'll first talk about our study of
the pre-optic region
of the hypothalamus in collaboration
with catherine dulux work
lab so as many of you know
that the hypothalamus the pre-optic
region of the hypothalamus
controls or modulates many social
behaviors and essential homeostatic
functions such as
sleep feeding drinking thermoregulation
and on the social behavior front such as
parenting mating and an aggression
so we actually took a two-pronged
approach
to characterize the cells in the
pre-optic region
including both single cell rna
sequencing and murfish measurements
due to time limit i will only be able to
talk about our results on murfish
and in this study we imaged 155
genes and these genes are selected to
based on these three criterias
first we selected based on some known
canonical
major cell type markers and we also have
many years of biological studies to tell
us what are the functional
important genes in the hypothalamus such
as the neuropeptides and receptors
and also we use the rna singles
rna sequencing results and the cell
cluster results to identify marker genes
for these clusters
and then added 70 genes to
the uh 85 pre-selected genes and then
end up with 155 total
gene for this panel so uh
with this you know here if i show you
all the genes for
a single field of view and this is what
you can see and then you can see
individual cells and you can see
individual animal molecules inside it
and then you can see the identity being
color coded
now with so many different genes showed
up you actually
your eye cannot discern that many colors
but if i show
for example only eight of the colors or
eight of the genes here
then you can immediately tell things for
example you can see these
red cells they express inhibitory
neuronal marker get one
so they're inhibitory neurons and then
these blue cells or science cells
express the excitatory uh
neuronal marker be glue two so these are
excitatory neurons and then these green
cells
are oligodendrocytes and so on and so
forth
now i also want to say that our
imaging actually uh the murfish after
uh multiple generations of development
and now it's
a very high throughput approach that we
can actually measure
tens of thousands of cells in overnight
experiment
so uh so this is actually the whole area
that we profiled in this work
and that is a two millimeter by two
millimeter by around one millimeter
volume and then you can see the two
millimeter by two millimeter view
and then uh you by measuring so many
genes
155 of them then we can actually use
those to do cell clustering
uh use the graph-based the community
detection method
and then the clustering results if we
first look at
the major cell classes level then you
can see that
now these are the major cell classes
that are uh presented here by color
and it's uh you can see some beautiful
spatial organization
not only that if we actually just move
from anterior to posterior only about to
0.6 no uh
let me see yeah about 26 millimeter of
range
and then you can see this beautiful
spatial organization to actually change
quite dramatically and
because we image 155 genes we can not
only by clustering get the major cell
classes
we can actually get also the uh neuronal
subtypes
so in this work in the these these
murphy's images allow us to actually
identify
70 different subtypes of neurons and
many of them are previously unknown
and of course because of this direct
spatial measurement we get the spatial
organization and i'm not able to present
70 different colors and yet still uh
let it make sense to you so so what we
decided to show here is actually each
row corresponds to
one different neuronal subtypes and
these are the 39 different
inhibitory neurons and then you can see
their spatial organization and how does
it change
from the anterior to posterior
and likewise we can see that for the 31
different
excitatory neuronal subtypes so that we
identified and see their
spatial organization
so we can not only determine the spatial
organization of cells
we can also determine their function by
co-imaging with
neuronal activity markers and in this
case
we used immediate early genes whose
expression is induced
by behavior stimulations as the activity
markers
so for example in this case we
let the animal to have the parenting
behavior and
afterwards we sacrifice the animal and
do the murphy's imaging
but in the murphy's imaging gene panel
includes the immediate early gene c
false to indicate which neurons are
activated or were activated by the
parenting behavior
and then you can see in this field of
view those are the red neurons that
express
a elevated level of c false and of
course we have our
cell marker gene panel uh that
apparently the colors are all
shown in a single color blue for all the
rnas
but as i show a couple of genes in
different colors then you can see
these uh red cells that are activated by
parenting behaviors of a specific type
but that
shows the preferential expression of
these uh
receptors calcitonin receptor and
bombarding
bombastic receptor three so we actually
use this approach
to look at the neurons that are
activated by
a set of different social behaviors
including parenting aggression and
mating
and for animals that are of different to
sexist and in different physiological
states
this is a lot of information here and
obviously i don't have time to go
through all of them
so let me just briefly talk about one
act anecdotes
so it's actually known that when exposed
to pops
virgin female mouse can exhibit
parenting behavior
and so do mothers and fathers but
interestingly virgin male mice that do
not exhibit parenting behavior instead
it actually is a
aggressive and then can kill puffs so
interestingly out of the some 70 type
of uh neuronal subtypes so we identify
to one uh stimulate with a parenting
behavior a
single type of neuron this inhibitory
neuronal type 14 or i14 was activated by
exposure to pop in virgin
female and then this actually is a cell
type that expressed
interesting molecules such as galloning
testosterone receptor and bombastic
receptor
and we call this the parenting cluster
or parenting cell type
and you can see that the cell cluster is
also activated in mothers and fathers
but in mothers and fathers there are
additional uh
subtypes of neurons that are
significantly activated as indicated by
these red bars
and the interesting one that's activated
in both fathers and mothers
is this inhibitory neuronal cluster 10
i10
that express oxytocin a molecule that is
known to be important for social
interactions
and then we also found clusters that are
specifically activating moms and other
uh clusters that are specifically
activated in that
and notably as you can see that
this parenting cluster i14 is not
activated
in virgin mail when it's exposed to pops
explains why virgin male do not exhibit
parenting behavior
but what instead was activated at the
inhibitory cluster i-16
which is also activated when the animal
is exposed to
other uh males which then a
will elicit aggression behavior
and you know so which is consistent
with the observation that virgin male
when exposed to puffs also exhibits
aggression behavior and won't go into
details but we also identify the
specific clusters that are activated
in female and male mice during uh mating
so just to uh summarize this part we uh
observed that genetically encoded
circuits are comprised of
transcriptionally distinct neuronal
types that control uh
specific uh hypothalamic functions
so let me switch gears and i'll talk
about
our recent work on generating the cell
outlets
for the primary motor cortex of
mouse brain and this is actually part of
the biccn consortium methods
and biccn early on shows the primary
motor cortex or
mlp as the initial target brain region
for comprehensive
mapping by a multitude of different
experimental
modalities such as single cell
transcriptomic profiling single cell
epigenomic profiling
spatially resolved single cell
transcriptomics
using more fish and also the
epiretrospeak method
that can allow the direct that they can
allow the
measurement of both epigenetic profiles
and retrograde spacing
and the combination of cache grand post
transcription profiling and then also
methods
that are you know these are self-help
targeting tools and other methods and so
on
all together the idea is to get a
comprehensive
understanding of the cell types their
organization and function
in this important brain region so this
has been a really exciting collaboration
for us
so i will talk about our murphy effort
in this case
we image the 255 genes in the mop the
primary motor cortex
and these genes are again a combination
of the known cell type markers
and the markers identified by single
cell rna sequencing
and as you can see that again we get
really high image quality here you can
see individual cells in the field of
view
and individual rna molecules that are
identified with the corrective barcodes
so using this approach and from the
single cell gene expression profiles
detected by murfish
again we used the clustering algorithm
and then identified
about three different cell classes
25 23 subclasses of cells and then 95
clusters so let me elaborate so this
three different cell classes are the uh
excitatory glutamatergic excited neurons
and the inhibitory gabaergic neurons
and the non-neuronal cells and
the each one of these classes are
divided into subclasses for example in
the excitatory subclasses
we can see these uh different subclasses
of
different projection properties such as
the
the uh
it cells that the intra telosonic
neurons the et cells that the extra
telotopholic neurons
the corticotrophalamic projecting
neurons and so on and so forth
and then in the uh inhibitory neurons we
can see the subclasses
marked by uh known marker genes such as
probably sst with
sng and then fives
and these are can also be grouped to if
by their uh development origin into ng
the right to south and cg direct cells
and then a lot of the non-neuronal cells
such as the oligodendrocytes the
image for oligodendrocytes ester stripes
and so on and so forth
and then again when compared with single
cell rna sequencing
that is taken inside the bicc in effort
we again get to very good correspondence
but we also see that there are some
flying splittings by murfish that are
not detected just by the single cell
sequencing
or the fine splitting that are detected
by sequencing
uh single cell rna sequencing but not by
murfish
so on but overall they're pretty good
correspondence and then i won't have
time to explain but there is
good reasons of why there's spine
splittings
that are detected one way but not the
other
but again uh because of the directive
spatial measurement
and we can map out to the spatial
organizations of
the neurons and here is all 95 a
different
oh i should also say here that these 23
subclasses are then
all finally split into each individual
classes are finally split into multiple
clusters and all together there's 95
different
clusters of cells and then here is a
plot of the spatial organization
of the 95 different clusters that are uh
in one coronal slice and
and you can see that you can see this
beautiful lamener structure
and then the appearance of that is
primarily dominated by
the laminar organization of the
glutamatergic neurons
because gabaergic neurons is a
relatively sparse
in this region and then
so we mapped out the spatial
organization of excitatory inhibitory
and non-neuronal cells
and then their composition you can see
that indeed the neurons are dominated by
glutamatergic neurons
and i should say that interestingly even
though the gabaergic cells
are not so abundant because we can
measure their location with a high
resolution and know each cell their type
we can actually get a highly
quantitative spatial distribution of
these neurons
and then they actually show very
interesting
layered organization too with many of
the inhibitory neuronal clusters or
gabaergic
neuronal clusters to be preferentially
resided in one or two of the cortical
layers
and of course the excitatory neurons
also show
layered organization with it cells
spanning
pretty much the entire cortical depth
from l to
three layer two three all the way to
layer six
while these etnp near projecting neurons
ct
and so on they're in the deeper layers
and interestingly we also see that at
the excited
uh at the the excitatory neurons can
actually subdivide cortical layers i'll
give you a couple of examples
for example here if we look at the layer
five
extra telescopic neuron or et neura
and then it's divided into five clusters
and it has very interesting spatial
organization
with clusters one and three actually
are populated in the upper part of the
layer 5
while cluster 5 is populated in the
lower part of layer 5
and the cluster 4 is actually only on
the lateral side of the
primary motor cortex and near the uh
metal sensory
cortex and then uh combining our results
with other experiments in the biccn
effort
we actually see that these lower lower
layer five cluster five is actually
specific
medulla projecting type of neurons
next uh let's look at a large group of
excitatory neurons
the it cells or the intratelostalic
neurons the ip cells is the largest
group of neurons in the mop which is
divided into
several subclasses l2 3 it l45 it l5it
and l6it now interestingly although the
motor cortex
was traditionally considered lacking a
distinct layer 4
due to the absence of clear cyto
architecture features
we actually observed a population of
it neurons in the mlp made of
five clusters that spatially reside
between l2 3it
and l5it subclasses suggesting the
presence of layer 4
like neurons in the mlp and we call
these l45it neurons here
additional experiments concurrently
happening
in the biccn consortium also provided
other evidence
for the l4 layer 4 like neurons in the
mlp
and then this finding is also consistent
with work from gordon shepard's lab
reporting l4 like neurons in the mlp
based on their anatomical and
connectivity properties
also looking at the clusters of these ip
subclasses for example here
here and here in the l6
we can again see that the excitatory
neuronal clusters
subdivide cortical layers in fact
the expression profile and the spatial
distributions
show that it cells that do not form
discrete well separated clusters
in the umap we can see that these
clusters form connecting patches
except for this small distinct l6ip
par3 cluster moreover the spatial
distributions
of these neurons shown here
overlap with each other and gradually
move
from layer 2 3 to layer 6.
now to find out the relationship between
gene expression
and profile and spatial position of
individual neurons
we calculated a pseudo time quantity
based on
the expression profiles of individual
neurons so basically cells
with more similar gene expression
profiles will be closer
in pseudotime now in the scattered plot
of individual cells on the
two-dimensional space of pseudotime
and cortical death we see that ant
neurons form a continuous cloud
rather than discrete clusters and
the pseudotime is highly correlated
with the cortical depth for individual
cells
now next we identify genes
which are differentially expressed in
cells of
a different cortical gap and we found
about 120 of them
plotting that that plotting their
expression profiles
out for individual neurons and ordering
the cells
based on their cortical depth and
ordering the genes
based on the cortical depth at which
they exhibit
maximum expression again we can see that
the gene expression profile of cells
show a more or less gradual change
over cortical death and we have a
similar plot to when the cortical depth
that is
replaced by uh pseudotime so
taken together our results show that
quite remarkably
the it cells which accounts for more
than
70 percent of the total excitatory
neurons in the mlp
forms a continuous spectrum of cells
instead
of discrete clusters
in our spatially resolved single cell
profiling
shows concurrent gradual changes
of it cells both in the expression
gene expression space and in real space
and was a strong correlation
between the expression profile of
individual neurons and their cortical
depth
and these results reveal a continuous
molecular and spatial gradient of it
cells
spanning nearly the entire cortical
death
now finally in the last few slides i
would like to talk about an exciting
technology advanced
that allows us to measure the projection
properties of these institute identified
neurons i.e which region
of the brain these neurons target to
which is key to connect their molecular
profile
to their function to do this we
integrate
murfish with retrograde tracing
and then we inject dye labeled
retrograde tracers to cholera toxin b
into various brain regions and we
developed a protocol
that allows us to measure both the
retrograde label
and the murphys genes in the same
neurons which that
allows us to simultaneously determine
the cell type identity through their
expression profiles and spatial
organization
of the cells as well as their projection
targets
with single cell resolution to
demonstrate this capability
we chose three uh brain regions
the secondary motor cortex mos the
primary somatosensory cortex
ssp and the temporal association
area t a as target regions
and inject the retrograde tracers into
these regions
and then here a typical integrative
murfish
and retrograde tracer image look like
this
showing the source neurons the
projection target
here shown in three colors for the three
targets and
the cell type identity here showing
different colors
so due to time limit i won't be able to
describe all detailed results but i'll
only highlight some findings here
we observed that each of these three
target regions
receives inputs from many different
neuronal clusters
you can see actually here only 10 or the
top 10
are shown they're actually more than 10
clusters per target region
and these are all from it cells and l6b
cells now in addition each of these it
or l6b clusters
also projects to multiple regions
so what we see here
is that the projections of mlp neurons
to other cortical regions do not seem to
follow
a one-cell type to one target region
rule
but form an interesting many-to-many
network
with underlying specificity namely each
region receives
inputs from a different composition of
clusters
interestingly in some cases we found
that molecularly and spatially similar
it clusters
can have very different yet highly
specific projection target
for example looking at the these uh
layer 6 ip neurons
we can see that layer l6 ip3
cluster mostly target pea but not
mos or ssp where l
uh 6 it1 cluster mostly targets
mos and conversely
mos mostly receive input from
l6 it one cluster you see mo6
primarily uh receives inputs from l61 uh
l6 it one cluster but not l
6 i t 2 or 3 cluster and t
a mostly receives inputs from l 6 i g
3 cluster now given that all three
clusters
have a similar expression profile
and highly overlapping spatial
distribution
it is remarkable that they can have such
distinct
projection properties now how such
distinct
projection properties can arise from
these neurons with similar molecular and
spatial properties
for example whether it comes from a
developmental origin
is an interesting question for a future
study
so hopefully although uh described
briefly i hope these slides convey the
richness of the information that can be
obtained from
such experiments now in the end i would
like to emphasize that for both studies
the high triplet of murfish in the mop
study we profiled
300 000 cells and in the pre-optic
region we profiled more than a million
cells
so to summarize in these two examples
i presented our efforts in using single
cell transcriptome imaging by murfish
to generate molecularly defined and
spatially resolved
cell atlas of brain regions
in combination with the neuronal
activity marker imaging
and retrograde labeling we also
added functional annotations to the
cells in one case
and projection annotations to the cells
in the other case
now many other properties can also be
measured by
imaging such as the mythology of neurons
and also in addition to using immediate
early genes
neuronal activity can also be imaged by
calcium
and voltage indicators as we know
many imaging methods are intrinsically
compatible to be done on the same
samples
either simultaneously or sequentially
while preserving samples between
measurements
so in the future it would be
really exciting to combine all these
different imaging modalities
to simultaneously probe the molecular
spatial anatomical and functional
properties of individual cells
and create such what i call molecular
spatial connectional and functional cell
atlas of the brain
which hopefully will greatly expedite
our understanding of how
different cell types are organized and
connected
to form functional neural circuits in
the brain
so finally let me thank the people who
have done the work
and the murphys technology development
has gone through multiple generations
of hard-working students and post-docs
in the interest of time let me not
enumerate them all
out while here but i'll only
specifically acknowledge the people
who are involved in the work of mapping
the two brain regions for the
hypothalamic
pre-optic region in my lab the work
was primarily done by jeff moffitt a
former post-doc
and steve at horn at current postdoc and
as i mentioned
this is a very nice collaboration with
catherine dulux
a nice and close collaboration where our
two labs basically work together day in
and day out
and we're also very appreciative of
the help from aviv regis who taught us
how to do self-clustering and shared
unpublished
clustering software with us and the
primary motor cortex
work is primarily done by a
mong jan and steve adhorm
and this is a nice collaboration with
hongway jones lab at usc
uh on the retrograde tracing front and
also
with the hong koi jen's lab at alan
brandt institute
who shared with us singles rna
sequencing analysis results
and together with us designed the
murphy's gene panels
and this work is supported by nih in
particular the bicc and u19
programs and by hhmi
and i also have a disclosure to make i'm
a co-founder of listgen
and now i would like to thank you for
your attention and open up for
questions
so the first question is how many genes
can you
image how do you determine the number of
genes to be imaged
uh yeah so is my voice on
can you hear me okay good yeah so
how many genes there is not really a
limit
so as i have shown in the talk
that in one of our published work we
have already demonstrated
uh imaging of 1050 genes
but we can certainly do more what that
need is means
we can do it by uh using longer
barcodes uh more hybrid hybridization
rounds
or we could actually even not
necessarily
increase that bit number but just
increase the density of the molecules
that we can simultaneously
image in one round by super resolution
approaches
for example using uh expansion uh
of the cell as we have also demonstrated
uh by uh you know i mean we have already
demonstrated the ability in published
work to combine expansion microscopy
with murfish
so as you can see from this you know per
round how many genes you can image was
that
was but still resolve the molecules is
one requirement but that can be done by
either super resolution or by uh doing
more rounds of imaging
there are some other limitations not
necessarily on the number
you know but on for example what kind of
genes you can image
some genes can be a bit short and then
if they cannot accommodate
a sufficient number of fish probes and
hence their signal does not rise above
background those short genes can be hard
to image
and also some of the genes may express
at a very low level and such a low level
that
their signal i mean the number of
molecules we detect
it does not rise above a false positive
that could also be
hard but that limit is is actually we're
very sensitive
our sensitivity is very high because we
can detect them
less than one co on average less than
one copy
per cell that kind of a level so so
that's
that's basically on the gene so your
other question is how many genes
do we want to image right you know for
any particular problem you said you know
how do we decide on the number of genes
that we often use prior knowledge for
example
you know if we have the singles rna
sequencing data
to say that there are these many
clusters and then we identify
the marker genes meaning this the genes
that are differentially expressed
between uh different clusters and then
with that
we can actually design a set of genes
and we found for a particular brain
region
often a few hundred genes is quite
sufficient
in determining high granularity uh
in cell cell type composition and so on
so there as both work we've shown we got
pretty high
correspondence with the singles rna
sequencing
without that prior data it'd be good to
use substantially more genes to
to actually uh you know make sure that
we can
cover all cell types and that's possible
uh thanks one another very interesting
question
um can you imagine dynamic changes
in gene expression such as for example
diurnal variability
and if so what is the level of change
that you require for it to be detectable
yeah so that i think we can because
uh as i mentioned murphy is
a a pretty uh sensitive
approach and then it has the detection
efficiency is nearly 100
and it can detect pretty quantitatively
the gene expression level
so on the order of a few tens of
percentage of
a change i would say should be
detectable
and even less than that would be
detectable technically
but on the other hand one do want to pay
attention to
the biological uh for example animal to
animal noise right so so if you measure
different animals that these
gene expression are already changing
from one animal to the other then we
need to have also
the uh uh state dependent changes such
as
the gene expression to be higher at one
time of the day than the other time of
the day that level change need to rise
above
the animal to animal or variability
so those we need to do some control
experiment to find out and then
but technically it is a very sensitive
and quantitative approach
should be a pretty good method
a powerful method used for detecting
that kind of
gene expression profile change
a technical question is what spatial
resolution can this technique achieve
it's actually very high resolution so uh
you know we can detect uh uh i mean
using a technical term it's actually sub
diffraction limit resolution so
so going back to the super resolution
work that we've done you know that the
diffraction limit
uh limits the the resolution of light
microscopy to
200 microns i mean i'm sorry 200
nanometers
of a resolution uh but in the smurfish
we can achieve better than 200
nanometers it's a little bit similar in
a sense
to our storm work that the neighboring
molecules
we don't turn on them simultaneously so
that they can be resolved at different
time
in storm we use the switching actually
in murfrees should some of these
molecules
are not detected in the same
hybridization rounds
so then they can be separately localized
so we often get a 100 nanometer
resolution
and even better than that should be
possible
and this question is slightly um similar
to the one on dynamic changes but it's
very specific and it's asking
can you measure activity dependent gene
expression
changes in neurons yeah we do
we we do certainly can and uh
for example using the the this uh
pre-optic region as an example there we
expo we
we let the animal to exert or exhibit
certain activity
and then we can uh uh map the the brain
the pre-optic region and then there we
look at you know the
the cells that are activated in sea
falls but then we can actually
cluster the animals that are naive and
the animals that have the activity
uh together and then we often find that
we can still see the same cell types
that are you know both a naive animal
and
an animal that exhibit behavior because
we can classify them as the same cell
types or
same cell clusters then we can compare
for
any gene of interest whether that
expression level
changed for the animals that exhibited
activity not only that for the neurons
that actually has been activated as
shown by ac false positive
signature so with that we can clearly
measure
the activity dependent chain changes
now and in that experiment a question is
you're looking at the c false
differences
when these animals are exposing these
behaviors
whether it's mating aggression
or parenting but have you
seen differences between males and
females
in that type of neurons in these
hypothalamic regions
right i think it's basically asking for
uh
sexual dimorphism yes we actually do
and it is a very interesting uh
direction that uh you know uh and
uh that that we can do more we have not
emphasized that
but indeed it's something that we
observed and it's indeed something that
we can do
uh there's a technical question here
that's asking you how can you tell which
neurons
that are retrogradely labeled with ctb
by murphy
how can you tell which neurons
so basically the retrograde tracing does
like this and i apologize if i have not
explained clearly in the top
so we uh inject retrograde tracer ctb
into a target region and then the
ctb the color toxin is already dilabled
and in a retrograde they travel to the
source neuron
so in that source neuron if we measured
for example
a red dye labeled signal
then we know that was targeted to the
uh ta region if it's a green dye labeled
you know ctp signal detected in that
neuron we know that neuron
actually projects to the mos region so
that retrograde tracer signal ctb signal
is
first measured and then we
uh have the label label the samples with
the murphys genes and then do the
murfish imaging so then this way
we can on the same set of samples same
set of neurons both determine the
retrograde label
and its gene expression profile
then there is another technical question
and it's uh does the imaging involve
many steps of labeling and washing to
label large amounts of genes
yes it does include multiple rounds of
labeling so what we typically do you
know is
there is an initial round of labeling we
called encoding labeling
there we place these encoding probes
on the genes and then the encoding label
basically
physically imprint the barcode we
assigned to the genes
what how how it works is the encoding
probes can hybridize to the gene
to the rna and it has the readout
sequences that are exactly
uh designed to be corresponding to the
barcodes
and then we read out the readout
sequences that are present
and then if it is a 16-bit barcode that
means we need to do 16 rounds
of readout probing with complementary
readout probes that are
exactly complementary to the 16 readout
sequences that each corresponds to one
bit
now if it's 16-bit then we do do 16
we if we do single color imaging at 16
rounds of hybridization but we often do
two
or three colors of imaging so that makes
it eight rounds of hybridization
or uh you know seven
six rounds of hybridization so then you
can do the mass if it's
a 21 bit and you do three color then
that's a
seven rounds of hybridization and
labeling and those we actually have
automatic fluid to flutic system
on our setup they just automatically do
that while the imaging is uh
being synchronized and acquired
then a question that again is um
based on technical which is it says i
have a naive conceptual question what is
the definition of a cell type
do i understand correctly that any
difference in transcriptome
would imply neurons that are of a
different type
that's a very good question i think
that's the
that's a question that the whole field
is trying to find an answer exactly how
to define a cell type
and can you define cell type purely
based on the
gene expression profile change and
let me put it this way gene expression
profile can change not only because the
cell changes type but also
can change when the cell changes state
right for example
activity can lead to changes
and you know cell cycles can lead to
changes and so on
so uh i would say that it takes uh
you know a combination of different
approaches
in the particular case in in
neurobiology
that to measure both the you know
the the gene expression profiles
and the morphology of the neurons like
the electrophysiological properties of
the neurons
and the the projection the circuit
connectivity
uh properties the function all these
eventually
uh to determine you know cell types and
so on
that said i think transcriptome
profiling is a very good
starting point because it's a very
systematic approach
and it is a quantitative approach so
because of that
you know we can get these different cell
populations
and a lot of them do reflect the
different types then we can do further
study in combination with other modality
of measurement
as i've already demonstrated in this
talk that we
combine that with functional activity
and with projection we can also combine
as i alluded to with other
properties a lot of them can be measured
also by imaging such as
mythology you know the shape and things
like that
so so with that we can then
using this initial starting point of
cell clusters to further delineate to
which one of these are cell type
chain uh cell different cell types and
which one of those clusters
uh only reflect cell state changes
thanks another technical question did
you have observed certain cells having
dual projections to both mo's and ssps
do they have unique transcription
signatures
or enriching specific clusters
so uh that's a very good question i can
answer this way so
the we do have observation
of the same cluster of cells
certainly even as the cells that are
very nearby spatially and belong to the
same cluster
can project both to mos and ssp
and do we have observation if the
question
asks for is that is there one particular
cell that exactly cell
actually projected two regions uh i
actually need to
uh further look into the data to to
answer
that question so it's not something that
i know
of the top of my head and do we have
unique transcription signature
uh or enriched in specific
yes so unique may be too strong to say
the projection
as i try to emphasize is a very
interesting pattern that's a
what we call a many to many so we what
we often find is
one target region can receive input from
many clusters
and one cluster can project to many
different target regions
and yet that doesn't mean it's a mess
without any rules so
we do see the specificity of a specific
composition or combination of clusters
that
project to a certain region on top of
that sometimes we even as i alluded to
to have very similar molecularly similar
and spatially similar cells that project
distinctly to two different regions now
we'll give rise to these uh
is what i said you know it's an
interesting question for the future
and uh have you used murfish for uh
doing studies to characterize
astrocytes and their interactions with
neurons
yeah that's another very good question
so uh
in all our uh brain murphy images
there are non-neuronal cells and
certainly astrocytes
and it is a very interesting thing to
dig deeper into these images to examine
the
the astrocytes neuron interaction while
we
currently have focused more on neurons
so but that's some
that's a direction we're interested in
now a question related to the
hypothalamic findings where you are
actually elegantly documenting
differences between males and females
as it relates to parenting rearing but
you only reported data on aggression for
the males
was nothing on the females so was it
because the females did not experience
aggressive behaviors or
or where they're older
yeah so uh that's an interesting
question
so uh uh my collaborator katherine
dulac probably can answer that question
better you know
so we have uh uh obviously
in these studies definitely have males
exposed to pop and males exposed to
adult male we have also
female exposed to pop and female exposed
to
uh to uh to adult male
and in the female exposed to pop case
we see the parenting behavior and the
female exposed to the adult
male at least to what we quantified as
the mating behavior
you know whether there were ever some
incidences of aggression i don't know
who had to ask
her and her postdocs whether they
observed that
yeah that was an interesting question i
mean one that we cannot forgo now that
we're seeing
aggression surrounding us unfortunately
now there's another question that um
came here that you may have answered to
a certain extent
which relates to um first of all they
say this is very exciting work
and they ask can you detect dynamic
changes
or is it a one-time measure
well technically measurements
that one measurement that you do is a
one-time measure right because these are
fixed
cells that are fixed at a specific time
point
and then the measurements you measure
reflect that time point
nonetheless you know dynamic changes
is something that is possible that one
can imagine
two different approaches that we've
actually taken so you could take
different time points
after a certain initial time point or
especially
stimulation you can you know get your
sample at different time points
and then measure or in some cases
we often find that we could do
pseudo-time pseudo timing of the cells
that can also
infer uh dynamic changes for example in
one of our work
what we actually did is pseudo timing
that reflect a cell cycle dependent
changes
uh you know in the what we see
is if we actually this is very
interesting if we actually take
advantage of our spatial resolution we
can resolve
what genes are in the nucleus what genes
are in the cytoplasm you know the rna
composition
and since rnas are born in the nucleus
and then exported on
into the cytoplasm so then if you
actually get the balance between these
two you can actually pseudo time the
cell cycle point
of the of the of the cells and then
there we can actually see a lot of cell
cycle dependent or uh the gene express
a lot of genes their expression levels
depends on cell cycle
now core pseudo timing can be used for
not only that but also for uh
development and and so on
differentiation if you go to
sort of the early days of development of
the animal
so through that kind of a measurement at
different
physical time points or the pseudo
timing when we'll be able to infer this
kind of a dynamic changes
yeah it's incredible work i mean it's
just amazing so
so congratulations and and
and i would you if you as you're looking
at the work uh where do you want to
bring it next to
and what are some of the challenges that
you would like to resolve
yeah so uh
so the the the method after
you know years of development
is uh already at a point that we can use
it
to solve or to tackle a lot of
biological
questions and the brain related question
is
one area that i'm particularly
interested in
but then one could also imagine uh using
this tool
to get the cell atlas of all kinds of
different organs and in different
organisms
one could also use that for disease
related studies and then one thing
that is uh you know one good example for
example is to do
a related studies to look at the tumor
micro environment
to look at the interaction between uh
healthy thousand
tumor cells and uh to look at the
interaction between tumor cells and
immune cells
and then to study the drug responses and
so on
so there are a lot of and then you know
there are also a lot of us
clearly a lot of biological i mean
development related questions
that can be addressed or was this kind
of a tool to look at how cell types
develop
and also cell differentiation questions
and technically indeed there are still
advances you know even though i say that
there's not really a limit necessarily
on how many genes but i did mention some
of the genes
are like the very short genes that are
still difficult to detect and so on
and then there are also interesting
questions that are related to to the
sequence length
for example uh you know
in the the the uh
the the spli the spice variants for
example right
isoforms and so on so so uh there are
really still
it's it's still a relatively new
direction that there are a lot of
technical advances that can still happen
well i want to thank you very much for
that terrific
talk and give you an opportunity is
there anything else that you would have
liked anyone to ask you that you want to
leave us with
i think we have had a lot of questions
already
and then i had already ran over time so
i just want to thank all the people who
has
uh listened to the talk and showed
interest
and you know it's uh it's a great
pleasure to uh
to to present our work in this platform
and
not only i want to thank the audience
but also
uh thank you uh nora so much
for doing this fantastic job monitoring
and
also i'd like to thank the technical
teams
of lab route and the nih to make all
this possible you know we're all
learning on how to do
remote conferencing so uh this is a uh
interesting experience and really a lot
of work from the technical support
people to make this possible so i like
to take this opportunity to thank them
thanks very much